Ron DeSantis who has not yet announced
that he is running in 2024
will not be at CPAC but he was
interviewed last night by Fox news's
Mark Levin now I we're going to look at
clips of the interview the interview was
completely deranged and delusional it's
not clear who's more deranged and
delusional is it Ron DeSantis or is it
the host Mark Levin but just for a
little bit of context Mark Levin has a
weekly show on Fox News and there's
always these story lines that develop in
media Outlets these sort of Cults of
Personality or story lines that are that
are used among different people the
storyline about Mark Levin is that he's
the more serious guy
he is a legal scholar and he writes
closer to what we might call real books
and he's so busy being an adult that he
only hosts a weekly show on Fox News
because he's really serious and so when
you sit down with Mark Levin and you've
got the dark lighting as you can see if
you're watching everything about it is
this is a serious interview with a
serious person and if you're so serious
that you can be interviewed by Mark
Levin you must also be a very serious
person it's all a joke it's all it's all
just complete and total nonsense and
Mark Levin is a bomb thrower partisan
bomb thrower just like everybody else
spreads this information it's just a
story that they make up but understand
that's the context Ron DeSantis is a
very important deep thinker and so he's
going to come in and have a serious
conversation with Mark Levin starting
with talking about the woke and again
the framing here is they interviewed
DeSantis as if he's already running for
national office he's the governor of
Florida don't forget he's the governor
of Florida but the context and the
framing and the questions and the topics
are this is a guy who should be on the
national stage and has a lot to say
about National politics starting with
talking about the woke yes you do have
to fight the woke in the halls of
government and in legislative Chambers
right and we have super majorities as
Republicans in Florida so we will win
all those fights but you also have to be
willing to defend your folks against
this agenda being shoved down their
throat from all these other institutions
terrible or these people aren't
necessarily coming up for election so
you talk about things with like the
young kids and with Disney
listen this guy is at the Forefront of
the most important issues the woke have
to be fought in the halls of government
and I mean look at the this major issue
of Disney Disney affirmed in some
nominal way
gay rights and so we've got to deal with
the woke folks but understand this is
what Republicans want to hear they want
to hear a lot of the same
pseudo-fascistic so-called culture War
issues presented in a marginally more
serious manner than Trump presents them
now that's a separate issue from whether
if a campaign gets going
constitutionally personality wise
DeSantis has what it takes to face Trump
the different question but this is the
same old nonsense he then talks about
how there was an attempt to impose
intersectionality oh the horror the
horror Florida our standards require
teaching all aspects of black history
and we think it's important we also when
we ban critical race Theory which we
were right to do well right or wrong it
was nonsense uh we also required in that
same bill that schools have stories of
inspiration about out great Floridians
and great Americans from a variety of
different backgrounds I want students we
need an entire thing about Dana White
and the heroic UFC events he held during
the virus pandemic right to to be to be
inspired that they can do well in
Florida you know as they get old
critical race theory is basically saying
some are oppressor some are oppressed
what kind of a message is that sending
to these very young kids so so we
require all of that and remember there
was no critical race Theory being taught
to young kids our standards in terms of
the basic history with the College Board
was trying to do they were trying to
impose CRT they actually were trying to
impose in a black studies course queer
Theory they were trying to impose
intersectionality and they were trying
to impose effectively neo-marxism and so
the question is is that something you
want to do on your own time yeah yeah
you're free save neo-marxism for the
privacy of your bedroom please
Sue that but for our taxpayers to be
supporting that type of indoctrination
that is not something that we want to do
now you might be hearing this and saying
David what the hell is Ron DeSantis
talking about here well he's talking
about the things that potential 2024
voters want to hear him talk about it's
the Glenn yunkin sort of routine run on
these things talk about these things all
the time which aren't really issues and
aren't actually happening the topic came
up of uh the Electoral College and the
Mandate and power that that winning the
Electoral College gives to a president
that's very interesting because you know
a lot of these small government supposed
small government conservatives talk
about you know we we actually should
take Powers away from the executive we
are they'll just say whatever they think
they need to say yeah it's hard to
remove them you know the Civil Service
rules and then the union oh and sorry
and this relates to the idea that they
be moan they would like it to be easier
to fire government employees that's the
context here rules and all the rest and
uh well there was one uh you know there
was a proposal uh that I think a lot of
us wanted to see under the prior
Administration to to do it the prior
Administration
who what was that guy's name schedule F
so anybody that has any policy role is
classified as a schedule F and they can
be removed uh by the president the the
left would litigate that but I honestly
think we would win on that in the
Supreme Court and I also isn't this a
great serious interview guys I think
it's one thing to have some type of job
rules for the the bowels of the
bureaucracy like your supervisor what
they can do president United States has
Article 2 power who controls the
executive branch is it the elected
president or is it some bureaucrat in
the bowels of the bureaucracy that can't
a lot of focus on bowels in this
interview he fired and so I think push
needs to come to shove on this but
whoever gets a majority of the Electoral
College is has the right to impose their
agenda through the executive brand right
and what they did with President Trump
was basically try to nullify the
election through not only bureaucratic
and Transit but malfeasance with the
collusion hoax and some of those things
yeah well really really throwing in
everything there so listen what they're
talking about here is that they're you
know the federal government is a major
employer and there are all sorts of of
jobs and roles within the federal
government there are some which truly
are
only uh bureaucratic positions they are
not in any way remotely political and
then there are jobs within an
Administration and federal government
that are obviously political the
president's cabinet for example and Well
on down from there and the idea was
Trump and some Republicans have gotten
the idea that in the middle there's a
ton of nominally bureaucratic positions
that are actually very political
and so rather than having those jobs be
protected by unions and and uh mediation
and arbitration all these different
things they just want to make the
president be able to fire all all of
these people and these are huge numbers
of roles and of course if you have the
view that these really aren't political
positions and these are jobs that people
depend on in a way that a secretary of
state is not likely to depend on that
job to feed their family that they
should be protected from a president
coming in and just going replace
everybody not to mention in a lot of
these jobs you really don't want to be
replacing people every few years is is
the truth so this is what they're
talking about making it easier to fire
people so again a completely deranged
interview
authoritarian while still pretending
that he's kind of small government
framed as a very serious discussion
between legal Scholars when it's
actually just the same tired political
nonsense with a little bit of different
window dressing and quite frankly if Ron
DeSantis decides to run for president
that I think is what the the candidacy
will be the same old political nonsense
and supposed culture War issues as a
shield for authoritarianism with
slightly different window dressing all
of these clips that I've played for you
here
will have them on our YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show but
also on the Spanish YouTube channel what
was that something is glitching start do
you guys hear that oh my God I gotta get
out of here dear God oh my goodness okay
let's close everything geez that was
really embarrassing the Spanish Channel
davidpackman.com Spanish approaching 2
000 subscribers let's take a break fix
all the technical problems and come
right back one of our sponsors is
private internet access most apps and
websites send tons of your personal
information to tech companies and data
Brokers based on your IP address they
have a disturbingly accurate
understanding of who you are and what
you do online even when you're using
incognito mode but you can put an end to
it by using a VPN the only one I use is
private internet access because it's the
only VPN that has proven in court
multiple times they are not logging your
activity they're no log practices are
even independently audited by Deloitte
private internet access also hides your
activity from your internet service
provider who is also usually logging
everything you do Online private
internet access is also lightning fast
for downloads and streaming content
normally only available in other
countries private internet access
couldn't be more simple take a second to
download it turn it on that's it you
don't need to know anything about
computers go to Pia vpn.com Pacman to
get 83 off that's only 203 a month and
you'll get four months free the link is
down below